I turn right now to somebody as I
mentioned prior to the break is one of
the best stories in the NFL there's no
other way to put it blew out his knee in
the 2016 Fiesta Bowl I mean blew it out
ACL LCL and Dallas drafted him in the
second round anyway people thought Jerry
Jones was nuts for doing it and man this
guy is balling out and has made Jerry
Jones look like a bandit for taking him
in the second round and his clear iview
collection launch is going to be going
down this Friday at the star in Frisco
Texas the star
Jaylon Smith here on the Rich Eisen show
how you doing Jalen I'm doing great how
are you guys I am doing fine if I had
told you the day of the Fiesta Bowl that
this is what it would be like right now
December 11th 2018 what would you said
man I'd be I didn't I'd be in this
police I did you know just full
acceptance because it's all a part of
God's plan but I'm thankful to be here
I'm happy to be on your show
thank you thanks for having me that's of
course Jalen and you know we talked
while you were going through your rehab
etc and I'm and I know you want to talk
about the here and now in the future and
we will definitely get to that but it's
you know I'm always fascinated by
journeys your journey is something else
to say the least
and I'm wondering how you got through it
I mean what did you what did you do
Jalen to get to this point where it
looks like your is better and you're as
good as new as ever
yeah honestly it was it all started with
me making the decisions persevere and
that's you know structure you know
through my clear idea what I'm talking
about a lot of focus is determined
beliefs and earned dreams that's really
helping me throughout this process for
just embracing each season that I was
there you know understanding that
probably was going to play my first year
you know being patient and allow my
nerve to regenerate you know laying a
great foundation to rehab my knee
because you know forget all of the nerve
stuff I had a severe knee injury ACL and
LCL so
we had to repair of the knee first we
had to make sure the knee was okay first
before we could even you know think
about the nerve so they were just a
matter of patience nothing really
happened on my time it was all the part
of guys so I've just been loyal and
embarrass Pond entire technique each and
every day I'm like it was my last and
I'm just thankful to be here so where I
am today to be able to show you know my
elite skills you know at the highest
level and last one on this you played
the Lions in week four and the the
Buckeye who is involved on that play
Taylor Decker plays for the lines did
you cross paths with him on that day
Jalen yeah we cross paths a couple times
didn't say anything to each other but we
cross paths a couple times you know he's
a guy that was drafted in the first
round you know very hard talented and
you know there's no hard feelings
but you know just fact of the matter is
he you know he pushed me after the play
you know but uh it's it's the game of
football
the last gladiator sport and you know we
all got to play it you know very tough
and physical
all right the here and now Jalen your
team's three and five what was going on
in that locker room at that point in
time man
you know trying to figure out our
identity in our culture and that is just
something that we had to come together
and realize that's the law you know
there was only one way that we needed to
go and and that's what we've been doing
so we have to continue that mindset and
coach gear does a great job at you know
preaching to us about that what does he
preach to you Jalen because again I
mentioned this to Byron Jones when he
joined us last week most of the most of
the football-loving population thinks
all he does there is clap no easy talks
about you know being locked in handling
handling the ebbs and flows of the game
you know being able to persevere being
able to knock
it's too high no when when everything is
wrong well and you know when things are
going and when things are not going well
being able to just stay mellow you know
so just being resilient that's what he
talks about and you know we've probably
bought in these sure half man and
there's no doubt about it and you guys
in the front seven I mean you get after
it
I wonder what your impression of Layton
Vander Esch has been everyone talks
about him quite a bit as well and what
he's been able to do is the first round
selection there and his drafting was you
know not nearly as I guess surprising in
many ways is yours Jhelum everyone
thought you needed a wide receiver in
Calvin Ridley and you take this kid from
the blue turf up there in Idaho and he
has just been a revelation I'm wondering
what your thoughts are on him and it's
something about Jerry and those Boise
State guys you know what I mean he
always flies and you know for us we
believed it'll never since he's got here
he's a guy who loves the game of
football
he's been very humble and buy a lot from
Shaun and myself so that's exactly
biggest thing I love about him but is
that you know he's a guy that you want
you know in your foxhole so what what
what maybe have you been picking up from
him what I've been picking up from him
she's the best tackle on the team
she want me to be honest he's the best
angle on the team so whether it's
watching the way he tackles or action on
you know kind of what he does you know
when he's going in for tackle degrees
like I say he's the best tackle on the
thing me I'm I'm a little bit you know
more diverse and he'll being able to
flip the fact you know blister pass to
rush the passer and you know run five on
the sideline all that excess stuff is
that reduced man he's dudes best tackler
that out that I've never seen so that's
that's really what I learned from him I
don't know you took down you took down
Alvin Camaro in open space with a goal
line right in front of them the other
night you know they were a liar but able
to learn it apply you know some some of
my lead skills as well so we work well
together
we've been able to build our chemistry
since OTAs or since minicamp so I'm just
very thankful to you know to have them
as my partner take on and we're gonna be
around for a long time usual in the work
you sure are jaylen what happens when
Shawn Lee does get back on the field
how's that gonna work are you all three
planning on getting on the field at the
same time you know I'm not a monologist
so I don't know how they're gonna do it
but I know they got you know they've got
some great guys and they lead guys that
linebacker who want to play and we care
for one another so we'll be fine mm-hmm
and Michael Irvin was the one who first
brought it to my attention I think was
around week three that defensive lineman
on that team Jaylon Smith we'll
referring to themselves as the hot boys
are you part of the hot boys is that
just the front for I'm yeah how does it
work here Jalen um the hot boys is a
very unique group there's initiations
that go down certain qualifications that
you have to have to be a part of the hot
boy okay and I'm one of those I'm one of
those initial members you know like I
said due tomorrow you know the ability
to get out to the pasture and blitzen
and you know just overall character it's
something that you you have to earn that
way to be a to be a hot boy and we've
got we've gotten two guys that are up
for a roundtable discussion and that's
Layton Vander s and Anthony Brown how
are the next two potential hot boy
members okay so I don't know if this is
like Mike club hopefully you can talk
about a Jaylon Smith here but I will
tell you this is what I will tell you
yes taco is the founder okay
taco Charlton is the founder and the
Marcus Morris is the CEO okay though so
what you're saying jaylen is okay so
what you're saying is that for something
that is crucially team-building
potentially
transcendent for the Dallas Cowboys and
your team you followed the Michigan man
is that what you're saying
Jalen you know I don't like the view
that because state or no today oh no we
don't really like all that Michigan
stuff however you know he's the founder
and you know when someone gets voted in
you know it we have a Ralph that were
discussing and every member of the hot
boys has to say I okay all it takes is
one no yeah you're in you're postponed
we got two guys up with a round table
right now and well we'll see okay Jalen
okay good to know
tell me about your glasses tell me about
the CEV clear eye view your collection
launch that's going down at the star on
Friday afternoon they're in Frisco Texas
yeah so man I've been a I've been
inspiring to be an entrepreneur my
entire life learn a lot from a lot of
people in these class you know two and a
half three years I've been able to
really learn a lot about you know
business and and you know access first
liabilities and all that good stuff and
um you know thinking about my message of
clear eye view you know having a focus
is being able to see it clearly it just
made sense there to go with some eyewear
especially from a margin standpoint on
the business aspect you know because
they make and sell and all an exit stuff
but this is something that was dear to
me because I wanted to be able to share
something with the world in my messaging
and quite frankly I look good in eyewear
you be you Jaylon Smith please come out
yep at the at the star in Frisco Texas
between 3:00 and 4:30 p.m. your cleats
for my cause my cleats what was it this
week Jalen what has it been like okay
I'm autism is so so colorful there's so
many different forms of autism and I was
able to display that on my Heath my
cleats but just one of the different one
to bring awareness you know my
girlfriend she's an honor and a be a
therapist you know for good Autism
Center back in my hometown and so I've
been able to learn
and being able to bend you know be
around the kid and it's just uh it's an
amazing thing it's it's a part of more
people I think and you know I just
wanted to spread awareness all right
last one for you Jalen I'm gonna let you
pound the table here okay I'm gonna let
you pound the table because well we're
hearing about is the Battle of the
Heisman winner versus the runner-up all
we're hearing is about is Oklahoma
Alabama we're hearing about Clemson
we're hearing about Clemson Dabo Swinney
they you know they've won it all
nobody's talking about Notre Dame
nobody's talking about him Jalen man
there's nothing like a golden dome you
know I think Jude Drew Clint do
drue tranquill linebacker he said it's
like nobody really likes Notre Dame
unless years Oh today so that's true
I'll be honest with you Jalen I rent
Rudy hoping he pops a quad I'll be
honest with ya you know that's me that's
just me though
you know we're we definitely got some
some debts to pay with uh cleanser so
looking forward to that challenge and
we're gonna be out here in my town so
I'll call it a little home fit advantage
if you will yeah oh that's right so are
you gonna are you gonna be there you're
gonna go on the sideline there we will
be traveling to New York for the final
game of the season so I will not be
there but throughout the week you guys
are here practicing all that extra stuff
I'll be around I'll be encouraging them
and getting them ready for the battle
but uh I like my guys all right well you
sir are one to root for man just you
keep bowing out Jalen is just awesome to
watch you just close and you just do
your thing and you and the rest of the
Cowboys sitting there at eight and five
and your journey and where you stand
right now and what's uh what's in front
of you it's just been it's just been
pretty neat to watch Jalen I've been so
I've been so humbled throughout this
entire process and I'm just thankful to
be able to you know put my skills on
display you know just getting the return
on his investment I'm just thankful to
be a part of America's Team so I
appreciate that you bet
and again just if any troubles happen
just find the Michigan man and follow
him
okay jaylen that'll work take care
jaylen that's Jaylon Smith at D Jaylon
Smith the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience